welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in a ventures endgame is one of
the many ways Disney Plus can absorb
your time for hours and hours time heist
including the bonus feature of an
alternate ending involving Tony Stark
after the snap appearing in the orange
colored soul realm meeting an older
version of his daughter Morgan played by
Catherine Langford now this scene was
described by the filmmakers earlier this
year but now we finally get a chance to
see it with the directors detailing
their decision to cut it the new
discoveries that are now coming up
provides so much insight on Starks
critical final moments his connection
with Thanos in the nature of the cosmic
forces of the MCU so let's break down
this scene in this episode of inside
Marvel okay the scene begins with the
moment Starks snaps back at the nose
time now we did learn that Robert Downey
jr. ad-libbed a bunch of alternate takes
of this line cluding lines like oh snap
and you are so instead this version
simply uses an alternate take of Stark
wincing in pain as the stones energy
surge blasters body the theatrical cut
version way more badass this deleted
version start gets a rectal exam yes
slowly cut and then just like they notes
the moment of his snap at the end of
affinity war we flash the whites and
then stark finds himself in the
orange-tinted soul realm now the effects
are not fully rendered because they
removed the scene early enough in the
process after test screenings to not
waste any of the VFX budget finesse
seeing all the surfaces they announced
his visit to the soul realm reconnected
him with Gamora as a young girl standing
beneath a reconstruction of the gates of
her home planet Xen wolf burry where he
first met her gave her that dagger here
Starks reunion with morgan is set in a
reconstruction of their daddy-daughter
moment to the yard outside their
farmhouse with that tent that she played
in and Morgan is now an adult's played
by Kathryn Langford Stark says I am
we knew you I like how he begins to
stammer his final words I am Iron Man
again still trapped in that split-second
and behind them you can hear the screams
and roars of the battle echoing through
is kind of an ambient sound as if
stretched out an extreme slow-motion you
realize that she's Morgan just worked
yeah it worked for me I got to live grow
up for you I can't answer Stark
struggles with this hint of his death
and he turns it says I'm sorry it's uh I
think I might have made a bad decision
I'm scared
mistake but Morgan comforts him you know
and I know it's gonna be tough for you
to let go but if someone had to do that
so the rest of us could I'm proud of you
and sad I'm strong like mom and I'm
happy I'm happy we had the time that we
did J and that you were there for me
until you couldn't be and so Stark
accepts it saying if you're happy I'm
happy
Morgan says I love you and start kisses
or cheek and gives a really awkwardly
delivered whisper yeah for that line
read alone solid cut before we continue
thank you to Epic Games for sponsoring
this episode
take back your planet in this cartoon
inspired hero collector RPG use my link
below to download battle breakers
yourself battle breakers was made as a
passion project by the small team at
Epic Games you assembled the perfect
team to defeat big bosses and epic
brawls that spin over a thousand
dungeons across volcanoes forests
glaciers and more unleash massive
attacks and special abilities to smash
through legions of monsters collect an
arsenal from hundreds of heroes and take
your game progress seamlessly across
both mobile and PC platforms saddle
breakers is free to play and available
on PC iOS and Android use my link below
to download battle burgers yourself and
when you do be sure to use my supporter
creator code new rockstars to help
support new rock stars and all the great
content we bring you thanks again to
epic games respond sir in this episode
okay back to this deleted scene the
director said that they cut this scene
because as they discovered while
reviewing the sequence in
post-production it brought the film to a
kind of halt
and despite Lankford's great performance
test audiences really didn't have enough
of an emotional connection to this
totally new face
additionally Tony's self recorded eulogy
to Morgan was another like a fart of
goodbye and an i-love-you 3000 so this
scene with older Morgan felt redundant
still I love that the scene exists
because it contains a few really
interesting details I love that the
animators included the single leaf
spalling from each tree to reflect the
way that Tony Stark has gradually
wilting away from life in this twilight
moment and I love that Morgan can't tell
him for sure what happens to him which
indicates to us that adult Morgan is not
an angel or a god or some external
spirit from the cosmos she's a
projection of Tony's own mind a piece of
his soul speaking back to him via the
power of the soul stone when Thanos went
through this his daughter was a
manifestation of his own guilty
conscience asking what did it cost
haunting him like a ghost judging him
for his genocide by comparison Tony's
daughter is here is a way for Tony to
help himself come to terms with his
decision and learn to let go that
projection can't be young five year old
Morgan start because then Tony would
still be left in a state of uncertainty
over what her future would bring but a
healthy confident adult Morgan Stark
signals to Tony that he has done enough
as a father and to now feel okay and to
move on she says I'm strong like mom
reminding Tony that he's leaving Morgan
in the hands of a generally more
competent and more stable human being
one that he is already trusted to take
care of his company for him this whole
moment for me
echos Andy Weir's beautiful short story
the egg in which they recently deceased
sold talks with a comforting cosmic
entity who tells him his death happened
at just the right time for his surviving
family and without spoiling it because
you should definitely go read it this
entity begins as a stranger but also
later reveals itself as something far
more familiar just like Morgan does for
Tony metaphysical pondering decide
seeing Tony go through this makes me
wonder what the hell did Bruce Banner
see when he snapped all the baby chicken
souls of the scrambled eggs he blip
banner doesn't have a daughter although
we know of so did he just like pop into
that orange weigh station like a guy
with a decay don't take your daughter to
work day
I actually think Hulk already told us
who we found the moment of a snap later
when saying goodbye to cap banner
suddenly looks down and says you know I
tried when I had to God let the stones I
really tried to bring her back I miss
her man yeah he's referring to Natasha
Romanov Black Widow was the person he
met in his soul realm actually Natasha
well earlier we never saw hope try to do
anything specific either then simply
snap his fingers together we really just
saw before and after so there must have
been some cosmic interlude in which
Bruce Banner went through a process to
find etosha soul and struggle to bring
her back with them the most artful way
to depict that seems to be this soul
realm Waystation it's not limbo for
people about to die because Stannis
didn't die he continued to live on as a
farmer making yummy stews instead it's a
place where your soul projects the one
person that's hardest for you to say
goodbye to for Thanos though is Gamora
for Tony that was Morgan and for banner
I think that would be a Natasha and he
would be unable to bring her back
because that projection isn't real is
just a reflection of your own survivor's
guilt well so there's a chance that a
hoax post snap attempt to find and bring
back Natasha was like a more confused
mad dash as Ruppel Hulk went through
dead Russians redhead after dead Russian
redhead unable to find the real Natasha
who does
are you Natasha odd no were you in that
my name is Natasha yeah but you're not
mine Akash you big green man oh good
I killed her what happens doing now well
just leave her here
yeah yeah I definitely got all that from
banner saying really tried to bring her
back
what's all there do you think this
Morgan Starks scenes should have been
included and Avengers endgame comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on instagram and twitter at EI vas
follow new rock stars and socials in
subscribe to new rock stars here on
youtube to join us as we go deeper and
deeper inside marvel and deeper and
deeper inside Hulk's haunted Hell
memories
[Music]